This model has been training for 24
hours and no luck. I've got an idea.
What do they call it back up again.
That's what every single section
dump these new papers say Gpu,
go turn it up and sell a little break.
Trying to minimize that loss to
let's say yo case or to bag it.
Put in active date. Do we want to do
it twice? He put out every was done.
I don't need a label.
I'll just want to do it without one.
As long as I'm breathing,
I'll predict the outcome.
Try solve it or I'll just try to solve it.
Tries to solve it or oh gosh,
right.
Oh by WHO's the Satoshi? Shout out
to the movement. Best notice BTC.
I was rocking blockchains back in
2014 before Cuban thought chips,
men currency NTX out. Take
a block. I need up fork.
The chain come at once,
coming to twice started spraying
and it'll build a religion to get,
I did it at five and this is my life.
I call it the school of Ai.
Go solve it or I'll die trying solve it
or to try and solve it or I'll try to
solve it or I'll
try it.
Just try it,
try it,
solve it. Or I've done
tried, Jimmy's got a nuke.
Oh My f being g from California
to Japan on that. Foresee.
Will anybody stop it? How about you
or me? Cause I'm a fight to the end.
Like a true, Oh gee, Yo
Matrix. Drop it. Error,
swap it. Delta hopping paper,
dropped it. Crypto, pop it,
I'll go solve it.
Try It,
try it,
salt it or I'll die trying solve it or
I'll die trying solve it or I'll die
trying out to all the wizards out there.
2018 this is our movement.